the early algorithms of YouTube were if
it gets more clicks show it more what
happened every thumbnail became women in
bikinis I'm dead serious right what ends
up happening then is a bunch of
companies start emerging Huffington Post
one of the first all of a sudden they're
getting massive traffic everyone's
clicking their articles they can read
the news now not through a newspaper and
comment on these stories what ends up
happening through the algorithms
Facebook says share the links that get
the most clicks what happens then what
gets the most clicks police brutality
videos things that in in uh make people
angry get the most clicks overnight in
the early 2010s we end up seeing my
favorite example is mike.com do you guys
know that started as a Ron Paul Pro Ron
Paul website yeah you told me about it
mike.com started as libertarian proon
Paul and with a component of anti-
police brutality because Libertarians
were very into this eventually however
Mike becomes social justice why it was
getting more clicks to go beyond police
brutality this whole machine's always
been in play